today is my first day as a coach on the
boys and i am really excited
i wasn't expecting it to be this
cutthroat i need to fight harder i'm
being too nice ariana grande just made
her debut on season 21 of the voice and
kicked things off on a high note
literally
on thursday the 28 year old singer
joined coaches blake shelton john legend
and kelly clarkson on stage for a
musical number rocking pink from head to
toe
[Music]
and once the coaches took a seat in
those big red chairs arie made sure
everyone knew she's in it to win it i
think my ears are better than my voice
this is my first season and
i'd like to think that i'm here to win
and she leaned on seasoned vet blake for
advice
give me some tips
yeah he leads by example talk over
people that's what kelly
a
does
welcome to team
she's warming up folks
naturally the coaches did what the
coaches do and playfully teased the
newcomer
this is god you should pick kelly
god is a woman i've heard i told y'all
obviously a reference to ari's hit god
is a woman
[Music]
thank you next
thank you next
thank you thank you next
yeah you get it
[Music]
contestant katie ray was the first to
join team ari after singing the bones by
maren morris
i'm gonna go with ariana
i have my first artist
and ari made one seriously compelling
argument
i know that you and kelly have babies
but i will have a baby for you to be on
my team
i'm not but i would
i'm kidding i trust all of your
instincts i only want to help you
execute your vision for yourself as an
artist
i might be new here but i have a lot of
experience as well catherine anne mohler
and von moogle also joined team ari and
when e.t caught up with the coaches
leading up to the season premiere they
said the grammy winner is a major threat
of course she's a threat yeah of course
she's a threat she is hugely talented
hugely successful and has legions and
legions of fans that know how to use the
internet and vote
we always come out like you know in like
like i'll go john goes whatever and
blake's usually laughs he gets the most
screams and and and well
and then
he used to you too and then all of a
sudden he was like can ariana go before
me because they lose their mind
it's embarrassing to follow her but
that's why we enjoy it see we wanted it
to stay that way because we enjoyed the
hearing problem
it exposes
my lack of celebrity celebrities
when ariana goes in front of a celebrity
yeah i think i have a hearing problem
what are your fan clubbers called
piranha
piranhas my fans literally don't even
have a name but
there aren't any i was a huge fan of the
voice i have watched many seasons and i
love watching the show it always has the
best energy and it's just such
like wholesome inspiring television and
i love seeing the different voices and
watching so many people start careers
for themselves it's like a beautiful
amazing thing and i've always been a fan
and i feel so grateful to be here
[Music]
you